oh [__] she hasn't given to the people
who listen to her for hours she would
sell it to take care of her her
granddaughter who spent her life caring
for her and doesn't have a family of her
own she throws it off the ship because
Jack needed it
died he's the bottom of the ocean and
you know it's crazy that's crazy she was
on the boat she was on the safety boat
right and she jumps off the safety boat
back into the real belt Jack would be
alive if she just stayed in the original
safety boat that saves her later exactly
right he there would have been rumor
then there was room on the door dude
they don't tell you this part of the
story but I bet you I bet you jack when
he saw she's only still on the boat was
like
yeah no I can save both of us I can say
but yes fine just come just but I think
uh uh they've proven now that uh who's
the guy who did the movie what's his
name James Cameron yeah Cameron they he
did a thing where they got the two
people to sit on the door and it worked
and they're like yeah that was like you
know that was weird you know what other
movies like this too The Notebook I
remember being a kid watching this movie
and thinking like he's
like why is this okay yeah and they
romanticized cheating but you know what
I think it is I think it's like what's
that one about I don't know the notebook
basically she it's like Again The One
That Got Away which is also a Katy Perry
song right but basically she dates this
guy in high school and they're in love
or whatever and then she they break up I
don't remember why but she goes on to
meet this really nice guy that like
traded her well all this stuff similar
you know to the Titanic but she just
couldn't get the old guy out of her head
and she goes and cheats on him for like
three days and then he like runs in the
rain and is like I love you and then she
leaves her fiance for this guy she dated
in high school she's in Alpha Widow bro
I actually never saw it but I had a
podcast guest who was explaining the
plot of it to me I was like this is this
is horrible yeah horrible story oh the
alpha the alpha Widow is like it's it's
really common in music and movies can we
do like a sequel to every Hallmark movie
ever where it's like so the woman who's
got a fiance and he's like a snooty
business this man and then she goes back
home to see her parents and then there's
the the nerdy guy who's all grown up and
Suave and he's like a carpenter now and
he's ripped and then he's very nice to
her and she realized he was the one all
along can we just have like a part two
where it's like they had a one night
stand and he was like yo I'm done like I
got things to do yeah I've seen you in
20 years later pretty decent I'll be
I'll act yeah no this happens
right every human being has a tendency
to wonder is the grass greener on the
other side and what Hollywood has done
is built an entire sub-industry of
telling women yes it is actually go to
the other side go check it out no it's
gonna be great you're gonna love your
time over there and then you end up uh
Divorced with a broken family or with a
person who actually doesn't treat you
very well and this isn't addressed and
we just keep churning out media that's
horribly irresponsible it should just be
like the day after she gets the the
hometown hero guy and she leaves her
snooty businessman fiance he like wakes
up and he's like I think you should
probably go and she's like what do you
mean I thought we were having something
like no I was just saying that so that
you'd sleep with me you can leave now
but why why would Hollywood producers
want women to think the hard-working man
who's loyal to them is bad for trying to
stop weird strangers from sleeping with
her why would Hollywood producers want
women to have that in their head I keep
saying Hollywood but it's Hallmark
Hollywood Hallmark all of it made in
Canada Hallmark is like way over the
line but all of these Hollywood movies
follow similar tropes like the man who
meets all of society's standards for
what a responsible man is isn't good
enough we either depict him as being
like you know bad in some emotional way
you know there's there's always a catch
the good hard-working man always has
problems in like The Lovable loser
always has a heart of gold and genuinely
cares for you it's like sorry no well
and the other thing is like whenever
they always try to like explain women's
cheating so like whenever you say oh she
cheated they would say well why did he
cheat what did he do it's the same thing
if she freaks out and is like hitting a
guy it's always like what did he do what
did he do to deserve this like or the
default is he deserved this in some way
where it's like if a man cheats he's a
dog he's evil he's just you know
whatever yeah but like here's here's the
thing like now we're seeing all of these
polyamorous relationships because
cheating kind of only really applies to
marriage and what we've created now is
this pseudo hybrid dating marriage thing
so here's how it used to be it was a a
young woman would date several men what
does that really mean it means they'd go
out for a cheeseburger and a milkshake
and then if they were like Hey we're
really getting along and we have a lot
in common this is fun they would decide
to get married now dating is first you
meet at a bar and then you bang at her
place or his place then they decide hey
maybe we should do this more often so
you've already like jumped the line into
like living together and and hooking up
but there's no actual commitment so it's
all just
a mishmash yeah exactly so so what is
cheating well cheating was like you were
married marriage is a contract the
reason it's called cheat is because you
have a commitment you are breaking if
you're just like randomly dating some
floozy or something like how is it
cheating if you don't have anything
formally set anyway and you could leave
at any time well I would add one thing I
would say like if you are dating someone
monogamously to discern marriage and
they can't be monogamous through the
courtship process that does tell you
something about them it's like all right
yeah you're not the one for me yeah but
I mean from from your standard Sheamus
they're like the person you're dating is
not going around having sex with a bunch
of dudes no it's also true yes so
there's not at least if she does I don't
know about it but what are you saying
like if you're if you would never date a
woman like that if you're so dating a
woman is like you're going out for
dinner and you're going to the movies
and then one day you find out she went
out to a movie with Ian and I would be I
would be like your first movie
they're going to see what is a woman and
I'm like apparently a liar and a cheater
I could tell Matt Walsh what a woman is
if you were in a relation relationship
with or if you just met a girl that just
rocked you knocked you on your ass
awesome but then you found out she did
it with 100 other guys would you still
be like whatever I'm going for it
there's a good question so um
statistically speaking we know that the
more sexual partners a person has the
higher the probability that they will
end up being divorced so I would say
there's kind of an imprudence in not
considering a person's history uh 100 is
a very big number I think like someone
can make mistakes genuinely repent and
then do the hard work to try to do the
Penance in fasting and prayer to
straighten themselves out and become
like a good holy person who would be a
worthy mother to one's children but
um I mean after a hundred I think that's
going to be pretty difficult I'm not
saying it's impossible but I'm saying
that it's not something that shouldn't
be considered and I think there are a
lot of people who want to argue that
that shouldn't be considered in it it
should yeah it's like do you decide with
your brain or with your heart you the
thing you have to think about and this
is this isn't me speaking as a married
man because I'm not married but I was
recently speaking to uh Jason Evert who
is and talks about these things and I
asked
he went to my high school really he
talked to your high school yeah he did
he did he's selling women dreams that
man yeah yeah I I yeah but we can get
into it I do like him but that's always
the same Trope with like the religious
people it's always like the ran through
check and like the guy that was a virgin
that like marries her at the end and she
only really gets away with it typically
because she's hot so which is yeah
that's a bad representation of his
musician I mean
I mean it happened like he's a nice guy
but oh that's what you're saying no I I
think that's a horrible thing to say
about him and his wife well no I'm
saying like that's what he said I mean I
don't know like I'm not trying to make
it a personal thing but can I can I
finish basically like that's what like
the wife goes up first and she talks
about how she was like slept with all
these people and then the guy goes up
and talks about how he didn't and then
the girl like gets married at the end
and yeah that's it's always the same
thing like so the girl basically gets
ran through and then the guy marries her
after and I'm like it's kind of selling
dreams and like an attractive girl can
get away with it but like the average
check it's like but but but I think
there's an important contextual
difference which is that Jason and his
wife aren't saying like go do this and
it'll be fine what they're saying was
like this was a horribly damaging thing
to do she wished she had never done it
and she repented and got close to Christ
and like did the work to undo her scars
and if it's genuine sure but I just
think like the issue like why I think a
lot of times Church like attracts women
that like have like that are a bit slug
I mean come on like let's just be honest
like there's a reason there's Catholic
girls have a reputation there's a reason
Church girls have a reputation well I
think because most people who are
supposedly raised in the faith aren't
they're told they're Catholic and they
don't go to church they don't well I I
think it's two because like the church
kind of sells them dreams that you can
do all this stuff and still have a guy
waiting for you at the end and like now
and the data just doesn't support it
it's like 50 of women are going to be
single and childless I see what you're
saying it very much sounds like the life
of sin followed by a death bad
repentance Christianity no no no no
because there's a difference there's
like and this is one of the distinctions
you have to make and part of why I
brought up Jason Everett is because what
he said to me when I asked him this
question on air was the question you
need to ask yourself is like what could
you tolerate 10 years from now in a
relationship with this person and that
is going to be partially defined by that
person's wounds the things that they've
done in their past so a person having
a very unfortunate sexual history
doesn't just or even necessarily mean
that they're going to cheat on you or be
promiscuous they could end up being
monogamous and faithful but they could
still end up having all sorts of scars
with respect to the way they view sex
with the way they view the opposite sex
they can become an angry nasty person
because of it and you want to know that
there's someone who has worked through
it there's no denying that it is better
to be a virgin right but not everyone is
and God calls people to marry
non-virgins as well well yeah but I
think my point is that it's like they
just sort of like I think sometimes the
church sort of sells dreams to women
because it's like you're kind of asking
a guy like to me something that's a bit
unreasonable like he why would he wait
when you slept with x amount of men like
for free well I think and I never and I
never see the church like like really
calling out like hey do not marry women
that aren't virgins I've never heard
like do not like they're red flag if she
slept with this many people I've never
really heard that so it's interesting
like they'll I really don't no no
there's a couple different things the
pull apart there I mean firstly uh your
CR I mean I've never heard anyone say
don't marry a a non-virgin
how could they yeah in this day and age
that's just that's not so much a church
thing as much as that is like this is
something people won't say one thing we
do believe in is repentance and that a
person can restore themselves with the
help of Christ uh God can restore people
if you cooperate with him but
and I I would add one detail which is
that it doesn't say like men stay a
virgin women sleep around and then get
married it tells everyone to remain a
virgin and it will also tell women by
the way that like the man you're with uh
he might have slept around he might like
have had struggles with a porn addiction
is real the issue is though like women
have so much more like like obviously
power on the sexual market like there's
so much more opportunity to do it from a
young age right so you're going to have
women that have slept around and men
that are a bit naive and they don't know
how to like like if you have a guy
that's a virgin and a woman that slept
with I don't know like however many
people right like he's going to be naive
and he won't really be able to pick up
on like certain red flags I think no I
look I think there's some truth and I
think the church doesn't really talk
about like the the baggage like they
don't really like talk about the baggage
that comes with this stuff and like
warning men about predatory women
because there are predatory women I
totally agree with you look I totally
agree with that there are predatory
women I think it's a big statement to
say the church doesn't warn people about
this because I know plenty Catholics
play plenty of Catholics who would say
like yes stay a virgin try to marry a
virgin I also know others who say it's
important to be yeah yeah okay well I
know nice well and I also know people
who would say it's good to be equally
yoked right like yeah if you don't think
you could handle that if you're a virgin
and this person uh has slept with a lot
of people that that is something you
consider in your discernment it's not to
say like you're evil because you don't
want to marry someone who's not a virgin
I don't think there's anything can we
talk about what as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible